bienvenue dans paf numéro 9 on va parler
de l'actualité mais d'actualité qui va
se produire cet de l'année prochaine
parce qu'on est tous impatients au fond
d'arriver en 2015 parce que 2014 a pas
été formidable donc on va parler de ce
qui va se passer de ce qui peut se
passer l'année prochaine en compagnie de
sephora nomani ça va bien ça va bien les
vacances donc voilà il en profite aussi
aux impatients de vous arriver à 2015
toujours impatiente d'aller de l'avant
très bien mustapha larbaoui bonjour
bonjour vous aussi impatience non il ya
des choses que pour lesquelles je suis
impatient il y en a d'autres on prendra
le temps quand même est-ce que vous
soyez est-ce que vous aimer les uns les
autres parler de ces périodes de fêtes
ou pas vous présente d'abord jean luc
madec bonjour patrice oui je moi j'adore
les périodes de falgos énormément bien
vous vous bossez
bonjour
c'est bien
trois dom au 16 août vous aimez et jean
charles lajoie dit bonjour l'édition qui
se porte bien vous aviez dit aimer les
missions les librairies jamais accueilli
autant de monde est-ce que les autres
est ce que ce sont des périodes que vous
aimez ces périodes de fin d'année de
fait ou pas ce qui est des gens qui me
déprime un peu pendant cette période
alors jean-luc travail on bosse mais en
même temps on a des petits moments forts
en famille j'ai eu la chance d'avoir
cinq petits enfants pensez bien que noël
ça va
c'est une période très compliquée
d'abord parce que c'est la période
hivernale c'est les pathologies donc
effectivement on travaille très fort
aussi
et en même temps en terme d'organisation
c'est toujours un peu compliqué parce qu
on a aussi des gens malades chez nous et
on vacances chez nous sur un peu
compliqué ces périodes là mais pour le
coup je rejoindrai quand même jean-luc
ça reste un moment où on se calme un peu
en famille et c'est plutôt joyeux
c'est un moment auquel j'ai tient
particulièrement moment rassembleur
festif joyeux oui
c'est très joyeux j'ai mes enfants qui
reviennent à la maison donc ces sont des
moments de communautés ensemble et c'est
très agréable
moi c'est tout à fait de la vie de
famille je trouve ça merveilleux c'est
très bien c'est sympa c'est
effectivement rassembleur c'est non
c'est tout à fait tangibles et agraires
l'année c'est très bien dit ça parce que
apparemment moustapha gaye
est un peu plus de recul pas forcer sa
basse et surtout que je suis absorbé par
la valeur ma profession en même temps et
puis voilà c'est ce qui me venait à
l'esprit entre mais très bien ça reste
un des événements de l'année 2015 ça va
être en politique les élections
départementales avec ba une claque
annoncée pour la gauche qui pourrait
perdre 60 70 départements
vous pensez que c'est joué déjà d'avancé
est ce que vous pensez que c'est très
grave ou pas pour la gauche moi je pense
qu'il faut surtout faire attention à
toujours annoncée des claques
démentiel parce que du coup ça
démobilise l'électorat qui voudrait
vraiment aller donner une claque à un
parti quel qu'il soit donc plus on dit
que la gauche va perdre mois elle va
perdre avec
des mesures parce que l'électorat mais
certains peuvent mobiliser
ça va sur mobiliser l'électorat de
gauche donc faut arrêter enfin après
suivant ses opinions mais il faut
cette déroute annoncée et sûrement pas
ça pas aussi grandement ses grandes
rollin jeudi et puis après deux 2e
partie de votre question oui c'est
sûrement dramatique parce que ce pour un
parti c'est moins d'argent c'est c'est
moins de moins de radio le conseil de
responsabilité une toile d'araignée qui
s'effrite un petit peu après il faut
rebâtir tout ça pour une autre élection
avec moins d'argent en fait c'est un peu
le fait la poule et c'est très compliqué
pc à la maison parce que jusqu'à présent
enfin quand il était dans l'opposition
dit toujours que le parti socialiste
gouverner la province mais gouverner pas
pareil c'est dire gouverner les régions
et pas l'état et c'est le constat qui
reste pour définir aubry on se demande
ce qu'ils vont gouverner bientôt mais
c'est probablement ce qui veut dire que
en 5ème république sous le régime
français c'est plutôt la présidence y de
la présidence qui domine alors c'est
jamais une bonne chose que de perdre les
élections intermédiaires les municipales
et régionales perdre le sénat mais
globalement la présidence écrasé et en
même temps elle donne le tempo donc
quand la présidence c'est de gauche est
à ce point malmenée bah ça effectivement
ça irrigue le pays jusque dans vous
allez province est intéressant lorsque
vous y perdre on sait que c'est vrai que
la politique nationale finalement a de
l'influencé sur des souris sol pour être
tout à fait indépendant c'est-à-dire qui
aime peut-être des très bons présidents
de conseils généraux de gauche qui vont
qui vont payer la politique nationale
oui d'ailleurs je suis moi même allé je
vais le dire quasiment choqué c'est
qu'il ya des il ya des mesures phares ya
des choses qui sont prises par la droite
municipale qui sont contrés par des gens
de gauche et vice versa alors qu'en fait
on est sur des thèmes très municipaux
très bas le corps très locaux et
pourtant on laisse un marqueur parce que
la droite l'a dit donc la gauche dira le
contraire pour revenir sur ce que dit
charles ouest ce qui me gêne c'est ça
c'est que il faut pas que les gens se
démobilisent pour aller mettre une
claque à l'adversaire je pense qu'on
mais surtout des claques à la france et
on a parlé du front national dans une
émission précédente le front national
qui a parlé beaumier parti de france
même si c'est surtout même si c'est
surtout les l'abstentionnisme mais moi
j'ai envie de dire comme certains hommes
politiques j'ai envie de dire chiche à
l'ump est ce parce que finalement le
front national qui dit tous pourris tous
les mêmes lui-même ps c'est une formule
et ça fonctionne bien pour dire ne votez
pas pour tous est ce grand ensemble moi
j'ai envie de dire chiche a lui-même ps
c'est-à-dire une espèce de coalition
pour 2015 la caravane à venir et là pour
le coup c'est il ya des choses à droite
il ya des choses à gauche qui sont
bonnes à prendre il ya un moment donné
est ce qu'on peut pas gouverner la
france autrement qu'à droite implose de
droit donc pourquoi pas un chiche art l
ump s mais c'est à dire cette idée qu'on
aurait presque eu sa place vers des
élections départementales ça ça passe
pas joe papp les élections sénatoriales
manière mais ça se fait dans d'autres
pays on peut par ailleurs en france mais
les coalitions existe dans d'autres pays
on peut très bien s'entendre sur des
principes et des grands principes comme
l'écologiste comme pas forcément les
marqueurs de droite les marqueurs de
gauche qui pourrait rester améliorer
l'éducation il ya des sujets sur
lesquels on pousse un peu plus en
retrait mais il ya des choses à mon avis
qu'on peut mettre en avant qui sont les
réformes à faire sont des valeurs
républicaines démocrates qui pourraient
forcément faire du bien à toute la
france surtout vous allez aller voter si
je réagis sur ce que dit moustapha sy
dit il à rennes il a raison de dire que
ça démobilise c'est vrai que si on lit
dotation ils vont prendre une claque qui
vont avoir que 20 départements ça va
démobiliser les gens les gens ne vont
pas aller voter pour mettre une claque à
l'autre et ça je trouve que c'est très
symptomatique parce qu'on vote pas pour
mettre une claque à l'autre on varie
tout cas c'est carey on doive allez vous
devoir dire c'est celui là dit
oui bon d'accord c'est ce que je dis lui
d'autres c'est jean charles qui parle de
cela d'autant plus d'accord avec laurent
c'est que c'est l'idée de mustapha nous
coalition je pense que ça renforce tout
le front national qu'autre chose mais ce
qu'il faudrait vraiment c'est que le ps
comme l'ump arrête de n'avoir comme seul
programme que de dire non au front
national on s'en fout du front national
quand on est à l'ump où il devrait avoir
des propositions avoir un programme est
le seul programme de ces deux partis
semblent être à chaque fois qu'il parle
de ça on est sympa front national on se
fout du front national qu'on arrête de
parler de front national et que l'ump
fasse des propositions nous déniche un
programme le ps nous fasse un programme
et on sera tranquille non gens chargés
seashell ump s contre front national
c'est chiche a lui même ps qui ont des
idées à gauche qui ont des idées à
droite qui peuvent se retrouver en
matheron métal mou des choses la fasb s
il a tout à fait finie cité aux
élections en chiraquie a été de 80 % des
voix c'est bien l'ump est ce qu'il a
fait jean-charles oui mais enfin il n'a
pas changé en cinq ans j'ai parlé à la
coalition droite gauche républicaine
démocrate sur des thèmes comme
l'écologie sur des thèmes qui peuvent
rassembler les français pas contre le
front national parce que par définition
c'est aussi en inde et dans des égouts
départementale où la droite a des
chances d'europe des traitements de on
est pas prêt de la coalition mais qu'on
parle bien je veux parler de lui
on peut pas dire non plus que le front
national est le premier parti de france
il a été le premier parti de france aux
européennes ce blaireau d euros vers le
masters c'est un râble en effet eu c'est
vrai
je suis désolé spyder nabila
des élections
j'estime sur le plan municipal il ya une
influence nationale qui est quand même
modérée je pense que l'identité de la
personne politique qui se présentent
reste qu'en même temps
la preuve avec paris ça fonctionnait
plutôt bien à gauche avec delanoë anne
hidalgo
du coup elle est restée elle est à paris
oui mais peut-être que l'identité des
hôtes ne plaisait pas après sur des
élections départementales régionales où
quelque part on sent représenté en
france par quoi soit par son pays soit
par sa commune ça ce sont des identités
qui soit un petit peu plus invisible un
petit peu plus flou donc là
effectivement il va y avoir une
influence
nationale du parti qui marche ou pas de
la même façon ce sera un vote
contestataire parce que je pense que le
gouvernement doit se remettre en
question c'est important très bien
quitter de nos conseillers généraux ou
de nos conseillers régionaux donc les
mêmes bien on connaît plus les
belles-mères oui est ce qu'elle est en
contact direct avec lui mais après au
niveau des cantons au niveau des régions
mais pas leur sécurité donc oui je pense
que ma dessus mais il ya des
personnalités
c'est quand même le national qui prime
sur ces élections là et c'est
malheureusement ce qui fera probablement
qu'encore une fois les grands gagnants
ce sont les abstentionnistes
hélas alors pour cette année 2015 y ait
plusieurs scénarios possibles qu'on voit
venir qu'on voit poindre soit des
scénarios catastrophistes alors il ya la
tension qui se renforce avec la russie
qui peut aller jusqu'à la guerre il ya
l'angleterre qui pourrait quitter
l'europe il ya les hackers c'est aussi
on a vu ça avec la corée du nord qui
pourrait prendre le pouvoir en partant
d'aider des dictatures sur la démocratie
et puis il ya un scénario un peu plus
optimiste qu'il dira au fond et à la
baisse du pétrole la croissance peut
reprendre
dans ces deux scénarios lequel vous
pensez le plus probable
moi ce que je vois pas du tout de guerre
avec la russie parce que je pense qu'on
a complètement occulté à cause de cet
épisode grotesque de hollande et sa
chapka
non mais on en a beaucoup parlé mais du
coup on a occulté regza rencontrés avec
milla il est allé voir poutine et
l'intérêt c'est que quel compte il dit
de quoi ont-ils pu discuter alors je
pense qu'ils ont discuté d'une alliance
objective et que et que franchement j'ai
l'impression que hollande est beaucoup
plus proche de poutine qu'on ne le dit
et qu' il ya des effets de manche pour
dire ou es poutine c'est pas très
sympathique etc mais que la politique
française n est pas fondamentalement
anti russe loin de là et qu'elle va
l'être de moins en moins qu'après les
etats-unis sont très anti russe mais ça
c'est une évidence ils vont l'être de
plus en plus mais que la france va
probablement se se caler et soutenir un
petit 2 au final oui c'est non mais
c'est plus que ça parce que si on
regarde vraiment un petit peu les
indépendantistes dans les régions
sujettes à la guerre en ce moment
avec la wii c'est pas si évident que ça
qu'ils sont vraiment les gentils vous
sont les méchants où sont les gens qui
pourrait nous soutenir après qui peut
voir c'est beaucoup plus compliqué qu'on
ne le dit et poutine est sûrement moins
abruti que beaucoup de gens et puis la
fin à une crise monétaire qui est quand
même voilà qui est quand même tu verra
donc peut-être que les sanctions quand
même ont joué mais d'une façon générale
est ce que vous êtes plutôt optimiste ou
pessimiste pour l'année qui vient je
rejoins changement ce que dit jean
charles
finalement
françois hollande incarne aujourd'hui la
politique de la france mais la politique
de la france elle est faite depuis
depuis maintenant quelques quelques
siècles et c'est vrai que la france a
toujours regardé à l'est même si elle
est très très proche de l'ouest et des
amériques en particulier la construction
européenne a toujours été quelque chose
à mon avis que jamais été très très
désirée par les concurrents
essentiellement les américains c'est
vrai que la crise avec les et avec la
russie à mon avis plutôt vu d'un bon
oeil également à l'ouest et la france
est entre ceux entre ces deux chemins
c'est à dire que c'est plutôt un modèle
de l'ouest et en même temps ce désir
d'un rapprochement à l'aise qui a
toujours eu lieu sauf que c'est là
ouh là où il ya quelque chose
effectivement de quasiment dangereux et
j'espère que la realpolitik va pas
prendre le pas c'est à dire qu' il ya
des rapports de force la guerre je n'y
crois pas mais la guerre froide
probablement ravivées mais c'est surtout
qu'il y aura des victimes il y aura des
gens qui seront à mon avis laissés sur
le bord du chemin sûr que si la france
l'allemagne l'europe occidentale
globalement se dit on va pas se friter
avec les russes on n'y a pas intérêt
probablement que ça voudra dire qu'il ya
des choses qu'on ne pourra pas soutenir
et l'ukraine en est déjà un bon exemple
que la crimée soit parti et que
maintenant l'est de l'ukraine soit
quasiment lâché j'ai peur qu
effectivement pour ceux qui sont entre
les deux entre ces puissants ce soit
pour le plus à se manifester
et pour le coup on voyait des victimes
alors ça serait terrible pour ceux qui
seront entre les deux mais je pense que
la realpolitik prendra le pas la guerre
froide continuera encore il ya des
intérêts économiques très très important
vers le rapprochement des états unis et
cuba c'est aussi une manière de dire les
états unis continuent à manoeuvrer
économiquement les mauvaises nouvelles
pour la réussite est donc
voir leur économie à flot est-ce que
vous vous êtes plutôt optimiste ou pas
pour cette année est ce que oui parce
que ça là il ya les deux deux scénarios
possibles dans melrose dit est ce que le
peut être que le pacte de stabilité ça
peut commencer à donner c'est ce que ça
va donner ça va commencer à produire des
effets en 2015 ce que je peux voir moi
juste de ma fenêtre par rapport à mes
clients ou les chefs d'entreprise que je
rencontre il ya un atout pour une partie
ou 2015 s'annonce pas trop mal en
revanche pour d'autres notamment dans
tout ce qui est travaux publics ça va
juste une catastrophe ça va être très
compliqué il ya pas mal de plans sociaux
qui s'annonce pour 2015 donc je pense
que socialement ça va être assez
difficile mais
ils sentiment qui a quand même des
petites choses qui se passent et que ça
phrénique ça pourrait redémarrer ne
donne pas tout de suite mais dans mon
deuxième semestre 2015 mais ça va être
quand même encore un peu confuse
j'avais écouté pardon je veux pas être
pessimiste mais
ça fait 40 ans qu'on se trompait faut
pas se faire d'illusions donc on ne
rectifie pas à 40 ans d'erreurs il en
salles un claquement de doigts on se
trompe de représentation sur le plan
national on en parlait tout à l'heure
c'est dramatique il faut vivre faire ça
je sais pas si on est maintenant à a
évoqué les voeux mais j'ai quand même
les faire tout de suite parce que vous
avez la gentillesse de me donner le
micro je pense qu'il faut remettre ce
pays à l'endroit c'est quoi ce pays à
l'endroit faisons comme les européens du
nord ayons des corps intermédiaires
puissant voilà qui ont l'apparence c'est
à dire ça vaille c'est non c'est pas
facile à dire il faut le faire
pour leurs bureaux avec les corps
intermédiaires cuissots doivent aussi
nous amener à réfléchir sur le buzz on
peut pas supporter que dans un pays
démocratique où des millions d'hommes
sont morts pour défendre nos valeurs on
en soit 70 80 % d'abstention vote il
faut que le vote soit vendu absolument
obligatoire ça à mon analyse et aveux
sur lequel moi je tiens beaucoup je sais
pas s'il sera réalisée en 2015 je crains
que non mais on peut en tout cas ils
travaillaient déjà le vote blanc qu'est
comptabilisés mais
il parie enfin que nous ayons un pouvoir
législatif représentatif de ce pays ce
qui n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui et donc
comment voulez vous faire il est bien
pas faire sélection pour les français et
les françaises prennent leur destin en
main c'est tout et qu'on arrête de subir
voilà je dis donc on va dit en effet
leur nom n'a parlement qui représente
pas la nation je veux bien mais on va
pas faire des élections tous les ans eh
bien on donne aux moindres sont à revoir
on demande déjà premièrement
syndicalistes qui vous parlez moi je
suis dans sa vie qu'elle est depuis 40
ans et depuis 40 ans je vois qu'on se
trompe donc
de parler d'une voix forte claire
intelligible pour que l'on puisse se
dire un déclin entamé hier plus puissant
ça c'est un voeu que nous pouvons
réaliser demain matin 2 le vote
obligatoire qu'est ce qu'on attend pour
rendre le vote obligatoire plus
l'abstention et le vote blanc pris en
considération on n'a pas réussi à
obtenir le quota des voix on recommence
c'est ainsi que va la démocratie g et
contre le vote obligatoire c'est une
aberration juridique
deux
noms mais pas on pourrait sanaa ça n'a
aucun sens un pas forcer les gens à
aller voter à donner leur avis plus la
plupart des les gens qui ne votent pas
existe en belgique c'est la ruée vers le
haut on peut pas dire que la belgique
soit le parangon delà de ça n'a aucun
intérêt je n'ai aucune envie là dedans
les belges qu'une envie c'est l'état
français ressemble à l'état belge
dix-huit mois son gouvernement alors que
même toi quand on comptera cette tarte à
la crème des pays du nord qui serait
merveilleux aller vivre en suède et puis
vous reviendrez en france très vite non
messieurs je sais pas c'est pas du tout
merveilleux ils ont quand même ils ont
quand même réussi leurs réformes ils ont
quand même aujourd'hui ne suivent pas
ces hausses qui est bien meilleur un
d'état d'un chômage qui va plus faibles
il ya lui-même des résultats il ya quand
même des faits une connaissance il en
fait après réforme on est d'accord avec
ans et qu'il représentait moi je suis
d'accord peut-être que notre ami
jean-charles finalement d'ubs il n'est
peut-être pas le même mode de vie s'agit
encore d'un mail
vote obligatoire sert à rien alors dans
ce cas dans ce cas on interdit aussi les
manifs on a aussi on attendait aussi
l'expression parce que qu'est-ce qu'il
faut se dire aujourd'hui tout le monde
est en colère dont le sens bien tout le
monde veut renverser la table très bien
mais en même temps qu'est ce qu'on a
fait jusqu'à présent pour que les choses
fonctionnent normalement dans un pays
démocratique comme le nôtre rien alors
si vous considérez qu'effectivement on
peut dire aux gens n'allez pas prendre
de positions on vous demande pas de
penser mais quand vous n'êtes pas
content vous autorise à descendre dans
la rue on a quand même une contradiction
dont il faudra parler à un moment donné
sinon sinon c'est marine qui va arriver
c'est vrai vous resterez pour le vote
obligatoire moi je dis pourquoi pas
effectivement c'est vrai faut s'engager
et de la même façon je pense que ce
qu'on écrit aujourd'hui c'est une
mauvaise représentation des politiques
il ya un fossé entre les politiques
entre les citoyens peut-être que si les
gens prenait plus part à la politique il
se sentirait plus à même de le confirmer
et plus le nom mais au delà du fait
d'être concerné plus à même en fait
changer les choses d'être éligible et de
changer les choses pourquoi pas moi ça
va il faut garder longtemps cette
émission je suis encore d'accord avec
jean charles pour le coup c'est vrai que
c'est un voeu pieux que de vouloir que
tout le monde s'engage mais en même
temps c'est des voeux qu'on peut
formuler au moins en début d'année on
peut observer des voeux donc on peut
mettre ce voeu que tout le monde
s'engage que tout le monde veut qu on
est bien d'accord le rendre obligatoire
bas ils peuvent éventuellement si c'est
obligatoire ils iront voter ils voteront
à la limite n'importe qui on n'aura pas
pour autant la bonne représentation
parce que vous obliger quelqu'un à voter
vous pouvez pas l'obliger non plus avait
bien noté la bonne personne parce que
celui qui demandera à ce que cela soit
fait probablement que ça sera pour des
pour des parties éventuellement qui
représente plus c'est intéressant mais
désormais jusqu'au même justement
jusqu'à nord champagne mais justement on
les prend ni pour des cons ni pour des
obligés font bien c'est-à-dire quelque
fois c'est à dire que s'ils doivent
voter en âme et création 6 iront voter
s'ils veulent pas voter ils votent pas
en revanche ce qu'on peut imaginer c'est
effectivement la proportionnelle sauf
que la représentativité et la façon de
représenter leur présence est
essentielle se pose alors le danger il
est d'angers le danger c'est que ça a
déjà existé on l'a connue sous d'autres
républiques
gouvernable et ça devient probablement
ingouvernable voilà mais à la limite on
est plutôt au moins dans une grotte de
l'ariège c'est moins une dose de
proportionnelle et puis si puisqu'on est
dans les voeux on n'est pas dans le
monde des bisounours j'insiste allons
vers le aller vers l'ump c'est encore
une fois pas celui de marine mais celui
de mr fin mais celui ci peut s'entendre
est ce que c'est parce qu'il était un an
plus tôt et que et que ce qui va se
produire en 2017 c'est à dire qu'on va
avoir un candidat de droite ou de gauche
contre encore déduire nationale et que
ce candidat s'il veut être élu si des
droites de aura besoin des voix de
gauche scellé de gauche aura besoin des
voix de droite donc que ça va entraîner
quelque chose que le juste quelques
raisons les politiques n'ont pas voulu
c'est à dire ce rassemblement des
républicains et pas forcément au centre
parce que le centre s'est déjà connoté
mais que effectivement légende se
retrouve quand même droit l'ump est
c'est quelque chose qui me va bien à
condition que ce soit construit sur des
plus de parts et d'autres c'est à dire
qu'on est con et des dénominateurs
communs et il ya des dénominateurs
communs en france alors les corps
intermédiaires seraient probablement
mieux représentés parce qu'on ferait
appel à des corps intermédiaires qui
seront allez on va dire
lavé de tout soupçon pour certains en
l'occurrence et pas forcément avec des
étiquettes marquer mais c'est la seule
chose sur les hauteurs au bal la seule
chose sur le vote obligatoire jean luc
est ce que vous pensez que les résultats
sera différent parce que toutes les
études de sciences politiques montrent à
peu près que même quand une forte
abstention les résultats sont à peu près
le même que c'est tout le monde vote oui
oui mais en tout cas il y aurait eu de
l'alluré en guise et c'est plutôt rare
bien sûr bien sûr à 15 jours et puis ça
responsabilise tout le monde
individuellement et collectivement at et
ça c'est majeur parce que pour l'instant
nous sommes en train de faire une cité
des responsables ont fait nul en
seulement au lieu de rendre l'impôt
obligatoire que jockey de rendre le vote
obligatoire sujet avait une âme et si
tout le monde paye et de stresa 2 euros
un raccord avec ce serait beaucoup plus
intéressant à la caisse quand on fait
des sondages on enterre on n'interroge
pas que tous les français ont droit aux
mineurs porteurs donc on est bien dans
des statistiques dont vous pouvez faire
même des sceaux demain des élections sur
un fil vers saint jean qui se déplacent
j'aimerais vous aurez les mêmes
résultats l'action de la statistique ce
lundi et c'est ce qu'elle disait sephora
est ce que vous avez des voeux pour 2015
surtout des voeux de savoir être sont
engagés les gens et m'engager moi la
première parce que sur une question il
faut commencer par se remettre en
question soit même à être plus altruiste
à être plus tolérants surtout plus
tolérants je pense que on a beaucoup de
progrès à faire de ce côté là et est
plus courageux c'est bien c'est beau
c'est beau très beau c'est beau c'est
pas facile
j'ai pas sommeil avec la sèche
très bien dit c'est
le courage j'adore ce délire lors
de courage à chaque fois que c'est un
homme politique qui fait quelque chose
de courageux ont dit voilà voilà
quelqu'un de courageux et en réalité
s'engager c'est pas du courage c'est
être soi même et défendre ses propres
convictions c'est pas du courage pour
moi c'est vraiment porter ses valeurs
ses portes et ce qu'on a en soi quand
même jour à l'ag que c'est à dire ce
qu'on va faire et faire ce qu'on m'a
donné du courage aux policiers s'il ya
un homme qu'il ya un homme qui l'a
montré récemment
bruno le maire par exemple qui est allée
devant une salle qui était totalement
hostile et qu'il savait aussi le premier
gagné le contrat de ciani c'est la
savane ce qu'on attendait donc le
courage en politique ça existe c'est
peut-être le renouveau pour le coup de
la classe politique mais le courage en
politique pour moi ça n'existe pas on se
lance en politique et en se lancent tous
courants et en et courage aussi on sait
qu'il nous reste très peu de temps
florence vous avez des voeux je partage
les voeux de sephora mais je rajouterais
un mot c'est l'audace le dos l'audace
pour les problèmes pour les
entrepreneurs dont les banques tous les
mets pour tout le monde que tout le
monde et de l'audace parce que dans
l'audace pour un an de l'audace il faut
avoir une vision une envie du courage
et puis avoir de l'audace pour soi mais
pour les autres aussi donc je partage
aussi mail truisme et l'engagement ça
moi j'aimerais qu'on en termine avec la
gratuité et l'idée de la gratuité que
les gens en europe 1 que les gens
comprennent que un déjeuner au
restaurant ce à un prix il ya des gens
qui veut ça se paie une consultation
chez un avocat ça se paye un médicament
ça se paye un bouquin à ces aspects
qu'on va on ne peut pas passer sa vie à
chercher le truc le moins cher parce que
c'est destructeur de valeur assez
destructeur d'emploi finalement donc les
gens se tirent une balle dans le pied en
passant leur temps à essayer de trouver
les trucs moins cher et de ratiociner
sur le moindre euro donc oui mais il ya
peut-être la crise mais
la crise se nourrit d'elle même je dire
si un consommateur ne comprend pas que
quand il va acheter une baguette de pain
à 30 centimes alors qu'on sait très bien
qu'elle va coûter au moins 60 il a il a
détruit la boulangerie c'est un truc de
base c'est quand on comprend pas ça
s'est fini c'est un beau combat merci
infiniment à tous les cinq ben voilà
j'espère que vous souhaitez 9e nos
meilleurs voeux à tous ceux qui nous
regardent vous êtes vous aussi une trêve
de très belle très belle fin d'année est
très malade et 2015 et à très vite sur
tv fil 78